the shake-up follows new scrutiny for
the president's son-in-law and senior
advisor Jared Kushner CBS News confirms
Kushner discussed setting up
back-channel communications between the
Trump transition team and Moscow when he
met with Russia's US ambassador in
December President Trump says he is
confident in Kushner Julianna Goldman is
at the White House with a look at Jared
Kushner's role Julianna good morning
good morning well Jared Krishna only has
a few months of government experience
but in that time he's become one of the
most powerful people here in the West
Wing and in the country but current and
former national security officials say
that his vast and undefined portfolio in
the midst of the FBI investigation is
cause for concern Jared Kushner is a
constant presence alongside his
father-in-law wearing several hats as a
family member with the ear of the
President of the United States - a
policy adviser who led a recent 110
billion-dollar arms deal with Saudi
Arabia if you can't produce peace in the
Middle East nobody can the president has
positioned Kushner as a senior advisor
and tasked him with some of the most
sensitive issues he wants to fast-track
Kushner's portfolio includes trying to
secure Middle East peace - leading the
white house office of American
innovation his contacts with Russia are
now making headlines but he's also been
a main point of contact with other
foreign officials in Mexico China and
Canada qualification number one Trump
Trustin New York Times reporter Sharon
laughs Ronnie Ayers says Kushner and his
father-in-law are similar in a key way
his experience has been a family
business they value loyalty Kushner
built his business with his own father a
relationship he discussed in a 2014
commencement address a lot of what I'm
going to speak about today are lessons
that I learned from the best professor
on how to get the most out of life which
is my dad ten years earlier his father
was arrested and later found guilty of
tax evasion and witness tampering and
now that Kushner finds himself embroiled
in an FBI investigation lafrana heir
says how he approaches those storms
depends on who you ask
if he feels someone has crossed him or
treated him unfairly he
he will be friends would say tough and
his critics would say vindictive for now
it's unclear how the end the FBI
investigation will affect Kushner's many
roles here at the White House it's
undoubtedly a distraction and Charlie
some top Democrats are now calling for
secured security clearances to be
reviewed thanks Johanna